REBOUND BACK AND SLIDES THROUGH
THE PAIN IT
TO CHANCE.
>>Mike: DRAW,
SHOT UP BERUBE. MAKES THE TIP
AND ANDERSON
FOLLOW-UP
CANES WILL POP IT FREE OUT IN
NICE FOR KOTKANIEMI WHO  AWLAWR
>>Tripp: THISFOR NECAS THERE RI
MARTINOOK.
COLUMBUS ZONE.
>>Mike: CHATFIELD
HE LAYS IT OFF AHO WRISTS
MY FAULT WE DO IT AGAIN WILL TO
DOOR IN THE FI A
POWER PLAY FOR COLUMBUS YOU'RE
NOT COME ONTO THE PUCK IS BRADY
SHAY.
UP TO  COUL
SIX, SEVEN CHANCES, MAYBE BUT,
THIS WAS THE LITTLE ENGINE THAT
MORE.
RIGHJENNER LEADING LOU JACK.AT
TERAVAINEN.
HE
>> Tripp: WAS S FOUND OUT ABOUT
TRADE FROM HIS THEN GENERAL
MANAGER. CAROLINA GOES UP 3-
AN OPPORTUNITYTHE
SLOT.
TRANDERSEN, WAS A TAP IN FOR NY